The joe rogan experience.
Oh,
that was another thing they found recently.
Man,
I wanted to talk about this.
They found evidence that a mass amount of people were killed in London in the 15
hundreds by a volcano.
This is 1258 there was a colossal volcano in 1258 wow.
This is amazing,
man.
So this is a new discovery that such a massive global,
national,
natural disaster has been identified in a small area of east London.
That's incredible,
man.
That is amazing shit.
Yeah,
we don't know too much.
You know when they,
when they really talk about history,
like what we really know about the past,
man,
we don't really know that much.
We don't know.
We just make a fucking assumptions
and every other week we come up with a new fucking assumption.
It's amazing how much we're fine,
but that fucking tape a Mars either that looks,
can't keep them.
Me Too.
I don't give a fuck.
You got to go to bars now,
now $14 billion when all this shit we got going on is fucking country bars for
what?
Who gives a fuck?
My boss.
I'm sitting there going,
this a [inaudible] gazing.
It's fucking table.
They made this in Burbank.
Well this is what I think.
I think first of all,
yeah,
they did go and it's awesome.
And when you,
you spend money on scientific innovation for space travel,
you're dealing with the cream of the crop of people that are trying to figure
out how to manipulate space and matter and transport things and how to,
you know,
you're dealing with the most,
the the most knowledgeable scientists on earth.
$2 strived and Joey,
come on.
I mean I'm serious and silly.
Every,
let me tell you this.
Everything that they do when they got to go with the fucking price,
I ex what it has to do fucking age.
We've got diseases,
we got fat kids running around and
March.
Definitely we should pay attention to that are saying we should go and explore
the universe.
Oh Bernie,
a little by little will fucking die in here dog.
This country is fucking dying.
We got time.
I don't give a fuck what goes on in Mars.
I don't give a fuck what goes on ugly and loved it either.
In 1529 I'm from the Church of what's happening now I'm buck.
If you care about that shit,
you got too much fucking time on your hands.
What's that got to do?
We've got kids.
We got houses.
Shut the fuck down.
You got billions of dollars to go to model.
Give a fuck about eyes.
Why don't you get this excited about the wars?
Because that costs a thousand times.
Don't get excited about and all that shit because it doesn't have to.
What the fuck?
Not that they'd been fighting for 10 years and I'm still paying $5 for fucking
gas guy that I didn't do.
The money we're spending on the war is a billion,
billion,
billions and billions of dollars.
Every fucking year I'm going to Mars,
Afghanistan,
Mars,
things,
a positive thing.
The Mars thing,
they're going to get innovation out of this project.
I need them in,
in everything else.
It's going to eventually lead to who knows what kind of space travel.
Eventually we're going to have
to do with us.
That's what the problem say is we can't buy shit that got not in the pocket door
that this is why I care about it,
because it's cool as fuck.
When that thing lands on Mars and starts taking pictures and sending it through
the sky and I see a room full of people who've worked on nothing but this for
years jumping up and down here,
it's fucking awesome and I pick up an envelope at the thing.
All right,
you're going to jump up and down to somebody landed and mark kick a bunch of
fucking gigs that they were white with blue shirts on and shit jumping up and
that's there.
That's what NASA is.
Matthew understanding put together,
and I appreciate travel.
You know,
10 years ago we hung out for years and you would talk about the moon landing was
fake.
Now all of a sudden you're happy about bucking wise guy.
Come on,
give me a fucking break.
What are they all connected system
that goes out of her day?
It's waste of thought.
We've got bigger things to fry.
Gas is $5 a tech.
We got this note,
Rob,
some guy who's a fucking commy cocks up a wall.
Fuck from Idaho,
Utah.
What the fuck is from against Obama?
Go into,
that's going on.
Good days.
His wife,
cause she's making fat.
Kids get fucking skinny.
That's it.
I mean what the fuck?
What the fuck?
We don't even have a president.
We know we don't have somebody to both for the next four years and we're worried
about fucking Mars.
Joe Rogan rarely about fuck what happened in England and 1529 we need to fucking
know what's going to happen at the next three years.
You know what dog?
You're right.
I'm about to have a baby and I'm fucking scared because what is he going to have
in 40 years?
What we're going to have,
we're going to be getting fucked in the ass by Arabs,
but a bunch of white people.
We went to go see if the Arabs are jumping up and down,
dare fucking gone.
Wait Til we get those wipe.
If they get excited like that about landing in Mars,
wait til they sniffed this Arab asshole has,
they're sucking my dick.
Cause my learning has,
does my daughter to have to learn Spanish or does she have to learn fucking Arab
in the next 20 fucking years?
That's what I'm worried about,
dog.
There's my kid have to go to school with 80 fucking foreigners or does she?
That's what I worry about.
So fuck march bro.
I want to hear about fucking Mars and a bunch of fucking waspy fucked with
Glasser's jumping up and down cause we landed on Mars.
There's a fucking mortgage is upside down his country.
Fucking pile of the students.
Are you going to stop doing stand up?
No,
I'm not going to stop doing.
So why would they stop pulling with rover on Mars?
But what's mine's got Joey's.
That's what they do.
That's what they know.
Level arts eggs,
they're already in
their art is creating something that can fly through fucking space for a year.
That's great land on your fucking time.
And I think they pay me.
These mother fuckers are using my money to go to fucking Mars.
They take half of your bucket check for taking half of my bucket check to go to
Mars.
Motherfucker.
You get angry when you,
they take that money and they go to war.
I don't even think about it,
but war is something that more than we need war more fun.
What?
How much money do we make by going tomorrow when we were to put a burger king on
why we think we need more,
what are we going to put on?
How are we going to pick up an envelope is they're in a fucking Juliet's happy
right now,
but what's going on in God cast is sponsored by ear doctors all across America
and the conspiracy copters and hired Julie to make people blow their ear drums
out.
That pissed
so many things going on in this regard.
Schools at closing,
fucking people see moral cities,
a clone,
human Bester and we gotta go to fucking what bars to give a fuck.
Listen,
Joey,
I said I support your hubris on us and listen bro,
I don't mind.
We've got to send pre Puerto Ricans.
I would establish a ride.
That's what needs to be done.
I'm going to blow up a fucking building or three black guys establish a wrap.
That's what it needs to be done.
Wore his money to fucking bottom line.
The square root of war guy is Didas and we've all known that Adidas,
that's the square root of money.
I don't see any DDAS and us going to Mars except taking a bunch of rich people
and charge them to take them to,
there's a quilt.
Let me explain to you.
Got To every fucking drone is flying in Pakistan and taken out al Qaeda.
If you believe in that shit bills every,
I agreed by scientists and that's beautiful and I'm with you.
If you want to argue about keeping people safe,
the best way to keep people safe.
Look,
I'm not a,
I'm not saying that I advocate drones because fuck load of civilians have died
from the use of drone attack,
but they eventually get that shit wired to the point where they can kill
everybody they want to kill.
That's where it's the scientists that are involved in making that shit at the
same scientists that are involved in making all sorts of,
I love in spacecraft Aircrafts and loving that.
Then making the technology.
Man,
you want to kill somebody?
You make up.
I want to see the bullet that don't need a gun for it.
I just got to go like business and a hitching.
Your head blows up.
I appreciate the scientist,
but not right now.
Billions of dollars to go to Mars.
We're only that Joey.
That is a fraction of what our military budget.
It's a title attached fighting for our freedom.
What does Mars has to do with us?
It's a Martian going to come back to Vegas,
so that's a crazy thing to say.
You are sending them it die.
One though.
The military is fighting for our freedom.
Is that why we're in countries that have absolutely nothing to do with and he's,
that's why and we invaded down.
It's,
come on man.
That's crazy side.
So that's fucking flag brother.
We're good.
We're bad.
We got to kill some much.
You got to break a fucking few omelets stuff to fucking make an album.
You got to break some eggs to make a few amens.
Whatever they're doing,
it's a lot better than fucking,
they're selling drugs.
The CIU sells coke at least that make them money,
Mars and got another,
here's the big thing,
Joe.
And every time,
every time they send something to like Mars or the urge do these missions,
they are also doing hundreds of experiments and these experiments are
experiments that we can't do,
you know,
down on earth where in a lot of these experiments lead to other things that do
help us out,
like cures for cancer and fucking time travel.
Well,
let's get the cool listen,
judge,
to be a dollar fit's going to be,
it's going to come a point in time if we follow the path that we're on now where
we might not be living on this fucking planet anymore,
we're human beings might pollute this motherfucker.
The point where we're going to want to escape and what they're going to do,
is it going to send shit to Mars,
to terraform just like they did in the movie aliens and they're going to put a
fucking fake atmosphere on Mars and that's going to bear a little escape colony.
Yeah.
Can I ask you the question?
Well,
what's he got to do with us?
I'm going to be dead.
I don't care.
He'll be fine.
I don't even know what else to do it.
I'm alive right now.
And when something lands on Mars,
I get geeked out.
Yeah.
I want to just see that shit.
I get names out.
Looking at the photos.
I'm like that,
that land.
Has it ever been seen before?
Is it like,
is there have been people that have walked on looks like fuck it,
Arizona as well?
You know,
it does look like Arizona,
but there is,
there's a real theory that's a fascinating theory that Mars used to inhabit life
and then it used to had an atmosphere,
but it was hit by an asteroid.
And uh,
that's one of the reasons why they want to keep sending things there and get to
task.
Because if it was above a planet that supported life like ours,
but then it was hit by an asteroid,
we realized that we've,
we've had mass extinctions on this planet,
at least two of them that were caused by asteroids,
you know,
hundreds of millions of years ago and then 65 million years ago.
And they know that there's been some just doozies that have landed,
but it's possible that one could land that just kills the whole thing.
That's a wrap.
Let me ask you something,
Bro.
What's that dot.
To do are,
okay.
Can you sell an asteroid?
Could you bring an asteroid to a check cashing senate dogs and you want me to
get my fucking money fucking as to what was going to vote for this year.
I mean,
I don't want,
could you fill in a right in Doug?
Stan hope.
Yeah,
that's what I was thinking it.
Doug Stanhope.
Yeah,
I can do any of you see what's going on in this country and we could get a lot
of people to down on this country.
Joe Rogan,
intelligent guy.
I'm a fucking Momo and I know that those both of them a bumps.
You're an intelligent guy.
You just looking at my face and told me you are not confident about anybody
who's running for president.
This country.
You and another fucking million people feel that way.
Sorry about that chocolate bar.
Fucking me up.
You know?
It's all right man.
I know what you're doing.
Just having fun.
No,
no,
no.
Fuck No.